Been away around 21st or whatever.
I don't think so. A month.
Hi Chad. How's it going?
I'm doing good. How about you? You still sick?
Yeah, I'm getting sicker. Wow. You need to have rest.
I rest, I rest, but It's not enough I guess.
Um,
let me see.
Is this about the workflow that we're gonna do? Yeah.
Let me show you. So I'm gonna do
it in my account real quick.
Okay. And then I'm gonna test you
to see how you do it in your account.
And by the way, um,
I think Open Claw will write this workflow for you too.
Oh. So a workflow is a series of emails.
So let me kinda show you.
So if I come in here to workflows
and if I look at like, um, Hannah,
I'm teaching 'em workflows.
So these are all workflows.
Um, you still, uh,
are you sharing your screen? I'm not seeing it.
Not seeing it. You're here, right? Hannah?
Yes. I'm teaching Keith
workflows. I thought you might wanna know.
Yeah. Okay. So look,
if we look at like, this is the group.
So if we look at like local newsletter hustle, if we go down
to like phase one delivery, uh,
I wanna look at one that has goal map.
Okay? Like we look at this, okay,
so there's 11 active people going through.
11 people have completed 107 are frozen.
And seven 6.14% have,
uh, met the goal.
Mm-hmm. And there's six emails in there.
There's seven timers. So if we click view, we can see
what this workflow looks like, right?
So there's the first email, it waits two days,
second email waits three days. See this?
Mm-hmm. Okay. Yeah.
And then we add, we take a timer
and we freeze it so that those people are stuck here
and they're not completed in the workflow.
So I can turn it on like this
and I can see down here that 90 people are frozen.
You see it? Yep. 91. Yeah. Yeah.
And then when I want to come over here
and unfreeze it, it's gonna push 'em through
and then I can freeze it again.
That allows me to build out a workflow
like one email at a time.
Does that make sense? Mm-hmm.
So whenever we do the re-engagement, actually
what we're doing is we're firing off a tag
that's putting them into a workflow
and then they're getting one email, two email, three emails.
And that's how it works. And what we're trying to do
is we're trying to bring 'em back over here to the green.
Mm-hmm. So if you look at me right now,
I have 1800 active clickers, 9,500 active openers.
621 people are inactive.
So I need to get 'em back in the green, right? Mm-hmm. Yeah.
You starting to understand this.
Yeah, these people are dead.
I'm gonna try to get them back to the green too.
And the way I do that is by reengaging them
and they're either gonna go back to the green
or they're gonna stay dead,
or they're gonna go, they're gonna unsubscribe
'cause we have a re-engagement system.
Does that make sense? Mm-hmm. Okay.
So, uh, uh, well come over here
and I'm just gonna go ahead and do the usual.
So, um,
I'll be like new gold offer.
Actually I should probably just do this in your guys'
account and then you can rewrite it.
Okay. Um,
I don't know if I know the password to this.
I don't. Okay, so, uh, do you know what the pass?
Let me try. Um,
okay, so we're going to gc,
let's take a look at how we've done so far.
So if we look over here, open Claw has been trying
to reengage this list.
So we can look at, um,
mg dot Yeah, that's the right one.
And we can look at workflows
And you can see that we have sent,
um, just the right one.
No, this is the old one.
Okay, so this was on mail gun,
but I think right now we're engaging here
sm Yep.
Okay. So we've sent 3,444,
it accepted 3,238.
It delivered 2,418. So it was super, super low.
And out of that 8% open rate,
9% click through rate, not very good.
Um, but we can look at this
and see, is this the right one that we've been sending out?
I don't think it is, is it?
What have we been reengaging with?
Um, oh, this is the wrong company.
We've been reengaging with Nick's company.
Um, lemme see something.
All this stuff is so confusing to me,
so many, so much stuff.
Um, is that what it is?
Okay. Um,
okay, let's try this one.
So this is the AI company.
Now let me see, that's where we've been re-engaging.
I got confused. Um,
and it's gonna be this.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, you know what? Shoot,
I can, I can get it for you, Chad.
Yeah, you can get it. 'cause I'm too tired.
I have not slept, I'm not doing very well today.
Yeah, it's, um, LING 2 8 5 1.
What is it? LING,
letter N for Nancy.
NG Uhhuh 2 8, 5 1.
Okay. Okay.
So,
okay, so we come over here.
So this, I can tell right now,
this is pulling in the old company, so we still have
to refresh it like it's just in the temps.
And that's the new company.
So if we go look at what we've been doing over here,
okay, that's it.
Broadcast, uh,
uh, that's not, oh, it's workflows.
Okay? So this is what we've been doing.
So we've sent, it says 355.
Oh yeah.
192 open, nine clicks.
So 5% reengagement.
Hey, pne,
Uh, I was trying to show you that you have
to check the stats and make sure it's actually sending it.
Remember?
Oh, yeah. It didn't send it.
Uh, I also asked the part whether
it was sending and whether it update the tag
and it keep the detail,
But it's not sending, right?
Yeah, That's what I'm saying.
You have to keep checking it.
You can't take its word for anything.
You have to check it
and you have to check it.
'cause clearly it's not,
it's not sending, right.
So,
uh, that's not good.
We're gonna have to get it to start sending. Okay.
Um, manually. No, not manually.
You just figure out why it's not,
why it's not actually sending.
It says it is, but it could be the issue with coffee, right?
Oh, yeah. All right. Well just look into it.
I don't know if Karthik's actually sent, do you?
Uh, I'll check his,
Yeah, I'll bet it didn't send.
So why don't you check? Okay.
Okay. All right. Thank you.
Okay, bye-bye. Bye-bye.
All right. So give me that, um, other account.
Uh, oh, actually I have it. Hold on. Um,
let back over here.
Let's,
okay, so
we come into our workflows.
Is this starting to become familiar to you now? Um, Keith,
Um, I'm familiar with that.
Uh, with the one that you're doing checking, well,
actually I'm, when I'm doing the blast, the email blast,
but it's not in a workflow,
but I'm getting used to the workflow
that you're teaching me right now.
Yeah, I'm following up. I'm taking notes.
Okay, so let me, mm-hmm.
Let me show you something. I'm object.
Uh, we, for
Tuesday?
Yeah. I don't know if you have a name
and
okay, so you have hotel name,
um,
and time
on page.
Did you take the information I gave you today
and plug it into the event?
Yes. So when
you open up the page or the event details there.
Okay, so let me just, so let me show you something
that's I think you can handle.
Okay? So before we do this,
um, I'm gonna come over here.
I'm gonna click here. Tour city date
and time confirmation link venue.
Um, I'm, do one more.
I venue address, um,
venue address,
a text that's find value.
I don't think I have value. Okay.
Group free
tour value.
Okay, so, um, I created a custom field. Yeah. Mm-hmm.
I see that. Okay.
So what we can do is,
I know you already fired off the tag, right?
Did you already send a broadcast? Yep.
Okay. Um,
well, I'll show you
what you could have done if you'd waited,
but what's the name of the tag?
San Diego. San Diego. This one? Yeah. Yep.
Okay, so we go to tag actions, we go to custom fields,
and um, we need a confirmation link.
Uh, okay, so let's do this tour City.
Uh, so you already added this? Yeah,
I You added this, right?
Is that the right date? No,
No, It is San Diego though, right?
Yeah. Mm-hmm. Okay.
And then we're gonna choose date and time.
Um, and that's gonna be what?
February 28th to March one, 3:00 PM to 12:00 AM
3:00 PM to 12:00 AM Mm-hmm.
Okay. So this makes sense, right?
I put the date and time Yep.
And the city.
And so now we have the,
do we have a venue? Think
It, uh, yes.
What's the venue? I
Think it's a hotel residence in by Mario.
Ine. Do you want me to send it wrong
Resident by what? Yeah. Okay.
Mart San Diego.
Here we get it.
Actually you don't need San Diego. You just
say resident in by Marriot.
Okay. And then, so you got the city date, time
and uh, venue address.
Can you gimme that, Hannah?
Okay. Send it on the chat.
Okay.
Okay. Um,
okay.
So you don't have to do it like this.
You can do it like this, okay? Mm-hmm.
And then for like a room,
Custom fields?
Yeah, just create a room for it.
Do you know the reason why I'm doing it this way?
Why? Because you never have to,
you can write one email and it could
work for every single event.
Oh, okay. I'll show you here in a second.
At least I think. So the tour is gonna be the room.
Okay. And then, so tour
room, or wait a minute name?
Yeah. Okay. Tour dash room title.
I don't know what the heck a title is. Okay.
And then the pre tour save.
Okay, so now we go back in the tag.
So the way we're setting this up, all you ever have
to do is update the tag.
Mm-hmm. Fields.
So add another tour Dash room
is gonna be, uh, George George McDonald.
Okay. And then last thing we have is the,
um, the URL.
So,
and by the way, the Madison's deal, he just wants
to have his own page with events, right?
Mm-hmm. Okay. So what needs to happen?
Uh,
gosh, my internet is so slow.
Okay. Wasn't there already chance?
I just don't know what the slowness is about.
Self master SMC 5 1 1.
Come on. Okay. So now we come over here.
Do you ever watch this, Keith?
Yeah. Okay.
You might start reporting the, the sales
and stuff when it happens, right?
Um, mm-hmm. Yeah. Okay.
Where did we put the, the events under products, right?
Okay. Events. Events. Okay.
So we come over here and we come over here.
Yeah, that's, uh, where I changed the dates.
Um,
So San Diego is over here somewhere
On the, but the last, yeah, there.
Okay. You need to put the venue, location
and address here.
Can you do that for me real quick?
Yeah, sure. So when we get the venue location, uh,
let me see if I can give you the path
and then you'll have to keep track of this.
'cause I'm so lost, guys, I'm so lost with everything.
This open claw stuff has screwed me up. Um,
Yeah, yeah.
Done.
There's a way, there's a path.
Um,
we
confirmation, okay,
you can add venue location.
It will show on the confirmation page.
Check it.
Yes. More.
Okay. No, it's not it.
Um,
got it.
Okay. Copy link.
Okay, so watch this, Keith. We go here.
Self mastery co.com. Okay? See this right here.
Question mark, what's the name of your event? 11, right?
Yeah. 11. What's the id?
Okay, so I'm gonna put this in the chat.
I need you guys to keep track of this, okay?
So I'll show you what that is. Um, but hold on.
I think that's the wrong page. So we're gonna come over here
and we're gonna look at the confirmation page for the event,
which is, this is
Madison's purchase.
Uh, that's okay.
Hold on. Let me make sure.
I don't think, I don't think Nick ever gave me a video.
Hold on, let me see. Go link.
Owen was supposed to shoot me a video. He never did.
Okay, so this should be Owen's video,
but in the meantime, did what we can do now
is we know this is a page.
So we go question mark.
Event ID equals 11. See that?
Let's try that more. There you go.
So now put in the details.
Mm-hmm.
Mm-hmm. So we can use that to send it to customers, right?
It depends. Is San Diego number 11?
Um, but I think the ID number is
30. 38.
38. Yep.
There you go. Yep.
Okay. So what we can do now,
and we don't have to have, look, we can simplify this, um,
bootcamp dash Owen.
Okay? So for right now,
um, I'm just gonna go like this.
Image.
Image, all right?
We get this bozos image,
save download.
Since he never shot a video for me.
Where did I save it?
I'm telling you guys, I think I'm getting old.
I think you can search Owen one.
I just don't know where I saved it. Save as,
Um, you can click the download button. Okay. There
In, it's in downloads.
Uh, no, the, at the sign in the top right,
the area also, you can check the, yep, there you go.
And yet it's a horrible picture. All right.
I'm telling you, man, my struggles are real these days.
Okay? So I want to get something that looks like an event.
Um,
I wanna do that one.
Heck, I don't, no, don't you have anything normal
on shoot, man.
Okay. Um, what's his free tour?
Do you have that one in the air table?
Something free tour self,
Uh, self-help, Free tour,
nothing.
Okay.
And downloads.
Most people look at this on their phone
anyways, okay?
So until he gives me a video, that's good enough,
but at least we don't have Madison's video.
But Madison's is gonna work the same way.
Do you guys see it?
Mm. Um,
it's interesting.
Which one? Pulled location, dates, time, venue,
location, dates, time.
Okay, I think I pulled this bottom one. Yeah.
Okay, let's see. Now
what the heck?
You paste it in a, in a different tab? Yeah.
Yeah. You know what guys?
I used to be really, really good at this stuff.
I'm not so good anymore.
Definitely gotten older. Okay,
So, so now, no, I think you just have new softwares.
Yeah. You think what?
You just have new software
and a lot of launches happening.
Um, so look,
it's the same confirmation page for everybody.
So
let's try this.
H TM L code.
Yeah, that's very nice of you to say that,
but no, I think my brain is getting fried.
H TM L Okay,
so this goes away.
This is the H TM L block. Now
preview.
Okay, but refresh,
ah, what did I do?
Okay, wait, it's not the right one.
It's, what's the ID again?
Um, 38.
Okay, so it's this one, which, okay, we need
to change this set up URLs.
So let me refresh it. So I gotta refresh it to get it
to look right over here, right?
Mm-hmm. The first time you created it comes in, but
after that, I don't just refresh it for you.
Okay? So this needs to be
bootcamp confirmation and we can just do like this.
'cause Owen's the main one. Okay?
Now, when we go to link, we should be able to put
event ID equals three eight.
Okay? So all you'll ever have to do,
you have the same link every time.
Mm-hmm. There you go.
All right, so now let's try to make
that look a little bit better now
that we're starting to get somewhere.
So we can come in here, we can come over here,
and on the left side
we can go like this and reload.
What do you think?
Yeah, Yeah.
Okay. Good.
The only thing, uh, we have times, don't we?
Yeah, we do have time. Um, lemme change that.
Is the, uh, you have the times in
the, in the event?
Yeah, we have Or San Diego?
Yeah. Yeah. It's 3:00 PM to 12:00 AM
I wonder why it's not pulling in the time.
Lemme check. Lemme 3:00 PM three two what? Sorry?
3:00 PM to 12:00 AM
Oh, okay.
3:00 PM to 12:00 AM right?
Yeah. Yes. Okay. Okay.
Can you refresh check?
Hmm. Oh wait, wrong
one, wrong one.
Okay. No.
Did you save it? Did you click off it?
Yeah, I save it.
Okay.
I, Um, well,
s**t,
let me see something.
So if I go look at his,
pretty sure we have all that working go to link.
His doesn't work either, you know. Okay.
I'll get that fixed tonight.
Mm-hmm. But you get the idea.
Yeah. So you should be able to take this,
pay this URL now.
Now let's go back to where we started.
And um, you should be able to click, add another
and paste this in there like that.
Mm. Okay.
Okay. So now that you have all that, we just need
to write a really, really good email.
Hey there, a quick reminder, let you know, event
with Owen Cook is coming up.
Okay? So what we'll do is we will put, uh,
he doesn't have a video, so we'll put the image
right here are the location details.
So what do we have? We have the venue,
uh, we have the address, we have the date and time,
or you could just do time separately, date separately.
Does that make sense? Mm-hmm.
And then, uh, click here, pull more details.
And then you also have your room number.
And then I guess you could put this up here.
So date and time. Okay, so is that kind of making sense?
Yep. Yeah. All right.
So, um,
I think that you could even do,
I think, so if we do this separate, oops,
I didn't wanna do Damnit, hold on.
Tour City. Tour City San Diego one.
Okay? If we don't wanna do like this
to give us more flexibility, we can do,
um hmm.
Custom builds.
So you have, yeah, we have to separate, uh,
create a separate for time and date, right?
So this over here, we tour date
or days, whatever, tour date,
and then this'll be
date, do you see?
And then we do another one,
and you have, uh,
tour time.
And uh, that's interesting. We don't have time.
We'll just do date and time
and we'll just see if we can get away with it
pre tour, okay?
If that doesn't work, you'll have to switch back, right?
Mm-hmm. Okay.
But the reason why I did that is
because you can do like
this, you can put it up here.
Do you see? This is how you use custom fields.
All right? So now
that we've done that, um, I'm gonna go ahead
and create the workflow now.
So we're gonna do workflow, add workflow,
I'm gonna do free tour dash Owen.
Honestly, if you think about it,
this could be the free tour for everybody, right?
Except we're putting in Owen's picture here.
And that's where you'd have to have a separate one.
Does that make sense? Mm-hmm.
Pre tour reminder, Owen, save, right?
So I'm gonna do the first one
for you, and then you're gonna do the rest.
So see up here in, the first thing it wants you to do is,
uh, I think we do this one save.
Okay? So now it's linked up here.
Now we click here and we're going to send an email.
Okay? So we close this, open this up,
and I'll show you.
So this is gonna be, uh, reminder one.
Uh, this will be from Owen Cook. We can do that with Owen.
We can't do that with Julius or anything, right?
So we can do Owen at self mastery.
This will be support at self.
Uh, oh, actually, I forgot. This is our first email, right?
So I'm gonna click on, mm-hmm. Okay.
So whenever, how do I say this?
I could have like five emails above me.
What that allows me to do is open up the bulk builder.
See, but I can't open up a bulk builder.
If it's above it, I have to be the last email, right?
So right now, this is the last email, right?
If there was one here,
then I couldn't open the bulk builder here.
I have to open it here because it's gonna build all the way
down, right?
So this is how this works.
So you got from Owen Cook, Owen,
and Self Mastery support@selfmasterycode.com.
And then we're gonna put in the subject line,
which if you look at the short code list, um,
hold on a second, let's see if I can figure this out.
Uh, custom fields contact field. Yeah. Okay.
So see here, uh, tour date, you got this,
and I don't know why it's calling it three,
three date and time.
Um, I'll call it
tour, tour date and time.
Okay? So if I copy this, if I remember right,
I should be able to put that there.
So then we have all of this in front of it. Mm-hmm.
See how that works? Yeah.
A quick reminder.
Okay, so now we've done that.
And so now I'm gonna come over here
and I'm gonna go like this, okay?
And I'm gonna go ahead
and open up downloads,
see if I get this guy to shoot a video
would be so much better.
So, uh, I'm gonna go ahead and, and, um, put some space here
and then just drag that image in here like this, okay?
And now we come up here like this. All right?
I can even put a countdown time in here.
I'll show you how to do that, right? So this goes away.
Mm-hmm. This says, Hey there, just a quick reminder
to let you know about, uh, let you know that your event
with me is coming up, right?
So then you got that,
and then you got, here are the location details.
Here are the, uh,
event details,
Right?
So you have date and time, and then we're gonna go ahead
and pull in the, uh, well, we have date, we have
to see if time works, right?
So we have this here.
I'm not quite sure why I did it like that, but that's okay.
Okay. So that's a custom field.
And then we have the venue, and
that's the custom field.
Okay? It didn't do it that time.
Lemme see, the good news is once you set this up,
once you're done forever,
but I don't know what the heck
that is, can you get rid of it?
Okay? So date and time,
date, oh my gosh, I'm pasting up here.
Okay, so date and time.
So, um, event dates,
venue, okay,
hotel address,
um,
uh, let's say venue address.
Venue address. And then,
um, yeah, you know
what we can just do, uh, let me think.
We can just put the room number right underneath it.
Tour room.
Okay? It's a little bit confusing for me.
I have a hard time with it.
Um, but you can just go like this too,
and you can just do, I'm gonna tell you guys right now,
this is not my strength doing this stuff
that we're doing right now.
It's super confusing for me. So I hope you get it.
Mm-hmm. Yeah, I get it. No worries. Yeah,
Because I'm not good at managing this stuff.
Okay? So event dates, venue, venue, address, room.
Okay? And then we could say, um,
this here, we can go like this.
Um, I'm trying to remember.
I think that we can go like this,
but we need to test it.
Mm-hmm. I think we can go like this,
but we can also say, I know for a fact,
um, hold on a second.
I know for a fact this one will work like this.
So I'll say, uh,
holy smokes, hold on.
Click here to find out
more une.
Okay? So then we'll go like this.
We'll click this and we'll go like this.
Does that make sense to you?
Yeah. Okay.
And then we can just go like this,
which essentially is the same thing on the page.
Yeah. But it'll be in another page or,
Yeah. So they can say
they get it, right? Yeah.
Wait to see you at the events. All right.
So here's what's cool about the bulk builder.
See now what I can do, but I'm gonna let you do this.
It can wait one day, it can wait two day,
whatever you gotta decide.
You guys gotta know, and it's kind of hard with Owen
'cause he's pretty flaky when it comes
to giving us information.
But if you were to get this three days in advance
or five days in advance
or whatever, then you could come in here
and do you see what I'm saying?
You could do wait one day and I do save a new
and look, all the details are already filled in over here.
Okay? All you gotta do is give it a new subject, line this
and paste your email,
and then do save a new again,
save a new again. You see how that works?
Mm-hmm. So you can see, here's your first email.
So you can just go ahead and copy that,
but you need to spin it so it's something different.
So they see something different, you see?
Mm-hmm. Okay.
And then now you have two emails, and then you can do save
and new, and then you got three emails.
And then four emails. And so when you're all said
and done, like if I click on save
and close, it just went at least, I think it did.
Uh, it should have, did I not save that last one?
Hold on, let me make sure it should have went
and, yeah.
Oh, it's 'cause I didn't fill out all the details, right?
So what I'll do
to kinda show you right now is I'm gonna delete this one.
There's gonna be two timers there,
but I'm gonna delete this timer
because what I'm able to do now is if I come over here,
Keith, and if I do another send email,
you know what I'm gonna be able to do from here?
I'm gonna be able to continue the bulk builder. Mm-hmm.
Because it's at the bottom. Okay?
So what's gonna happen, guys, that's,
so you need to keep adding more.
Does that make sense? Yeah. Okay. So what's gonna happen?
I would at least do like two or
three probably, I don't know.
It's, it's hard because Owen doesn't give us details very
well, but mm-hmm.
Like days, Wednesday, Thursday, Friday, yeah. Okay.
I mean, we could also send 'em like hours apart too, right?
Um, because I would have it to where you,
when you get the event details, you load the tags
and that way you can kind of come in here
and pause where you want them to stop or whatever,
or I don't even actually know how we're gonna do that.
To be honest with you. Probably
what you can do is if you have like a baseline, like three
or four emails here
and you know that he's only giving you two days notice,
you could come in here really quick
and change the timers real quick
so it makes sense with the days you have.
Does that make sense? Mm-hmm.
So if you have enough time to send it days
and apart, you're good.
But if he only gives you two days,
then maybe send one today, two tomorrow,
and that way you can change it to ours.
That way the emails get to him before the event.
Does that make sense? Mm-hmm. Okay.
So you understand how to continue building this out, right?
Because I'm gonna let you do this, okay?
So the name of this tag is free tour reminder.
There's no the name of the workflow,
but there's no tags here, right?
So what we're gonna do is we're gonna go back into that tag.
And when that tag triggers, so you loaded 20 today,
but you can reload the 20 again.
When that tag triggers, we want it to go into that workflow.
See, right now it's going to, it is going into the workflow.
Um, free tour follow up. Hold on a second.
Didn't we just create that? Was that workflow already there?
No. Tour of follow up? How the hell did he get it's on?
How did he get added? I didn't add it. Did I?
This, this workflow, didn't we just create it
or No, I think that's the old one.
It's already existed before.
All right, well when this tag fires off,
okay, here's what's gonna happen.
See this over here. Mm-hmm. Make sure all this is correct.
So for every single tag, when you get the details,
number one, you go event, you go update the event, uh,
in Manford, right?
Mm-hmm. Number two, you update your tag details.
And what happens is when you import these 20 people into
this tag, their custom fields
get updated with the contact record in that tag
so that when the email sends out, it automatically populates
the fields that they have for that specific contact record.
So all of these tags are gonna go into the same exact email,
but it's based on what's assigned to the contact record.
And the contact record gets updated when the tag fires off.
Do you understand? Mm-hmm.
So if we go look, if we look at like this person,
if we look at fields, contact fields,
um, yeah, you can see all this information.
We also have custom fields.
It's just not filled in, but it is assigned in the
database to that person.
I'll get, I'll get it to where you can see it here, but,
but that's how it's, it's updated the contact records.
So when this person opens their email, that's what they see.
Does that make any sense to you? Mm-hmm.
So let's, so let's test this out, right?
So, um, I'm gonna come over here
to tags and I'm gonna come over here
and I'm gonna test this tag mage
nicely, c nicely 32 at gmail com.
I don't have to put in a phone number,
but I'm going to, okay, so that tag just fired off.
All right? Now let's make sure if we go into C nicely,
32, okay, here it is.
Here's the tag. There it is. You see that? Mm-hmm.
Okay, so if we open this up now
and, uh, not seeing,
seeing this, I'm not seeing
where it fired an email.
Hold on a second, lemme refresh it, lemme check my email
and see we are
using SM for that, right?
See nicely. 32. Okay?
Why isn't it firing off an email to me?
See, nicely 32, is it saying it's not a legitimate email?
Okay, let's try it again.
Okay, let's try this. Test fire tag.
Oops, pH.
Okay, fire, let's see if you get an email.
Um,
hold on.
Is that workflow active?
So it's this one? Yeah, it's active.
Oh, hold on a second.
Isn't this the one we just did?
Is this the one we just did? No, this is not the one No,
On the right side,
if you're gonna go back in the workflow,
Okay, which Pretty two reminder o on the right side?
Yep, right side.
Okay, I gonna delete this.
Okay, so it's only this one now, right? Yeah.
Okay. See, there's no tags assigned, that's why. Okay.
'cause I, I, I linked it to the old one
and the old one wasn't live.
Okay, so let's do this for reals.
Now it actually fooled you too
because it was a similar looking name.
Yeah. Okay. So, oh man, this stuff's confusing.
All right, save. All right, now let's try it again.
So it added it, it fired the tag,
but there was no email for it to send.
Here's my question though.
You said it was 38 and you have it as 11. Do you see that?
So this is the problem, right?
You're gonna see San Diego come up over and over and over
and over and over, but what you have
to do is you have to create a new tag.
So you'll have a bunch of 38 tags. Does that make sense?
Or a bunch of San Diego tags with different numbers.
Do you guys, do you understand
or no, each event is separate and it needs to be
because you don't wanna put more people
In San Diego, okay?
You, you, you wanna keep these separate.
Like you want to have 11 San Diego, 22 San Diego,
40 San Diego. Does that make sense?
Mm-hmm. And what you can do
to keep it super organized is you can come over here
and you can say, um, a RC
archive, uh,
um, Owen tour.
So when something's done, you can just go change the group.
And that way it doesn't appear over here anymore.
You only have active ones. Does that make sense to you?
See, I, this one that says archives.
So when an event's done,
you can just put it under this group
and that way it's outta your hair, okay?
Okay. Yeah. How will you do that?
How will you, how to move it?
Update. Okay. Got it.
This, I mean, if you were good at go high level,
this software's pretty freaking easy, dude.
It's just, there's a bit of a learning curve
'cause it's, it's, it's so simple from everything else
that it's complicated.
Okay, so now we're gonna see
if
you received it.
So here you are, right here. Okay. It sent it.
See how there's a new contact? That meeting? Mm-hmm.
Said it sent out email. Okay, so let's go see. Oh yeah,
There is email Workflows.
Free tour reminder Owen. Active. Okay, do you see it?
Yeah. All right. Now if you open it up, how's it look?
Still not got it in my email,
But Hannah saw it.
No, I, I'm just looking at your screen.
Got it. Well it says it sent it to you.
Check spam and everything.
Yeah, I think there's a kind
of a delay when sending this from gc.
Yeah, There's Nordic,
There's a delay from sending from SMTP for sure.
It's not gc, it's SMTP
'cause mail done's really fast. So let's try this. I
Got here.
Yeah, I got it here. Yeah, I got it.
And did it populate all the details
In my, the date did not What? Didn't it populate
Event dates?
Is that the only thing? Yep.
Is everything else there?
Yeah, residence is good or the venue is good.
Address, venue address, room number. It's good.
Oh, hold on, let me check. The image is not viewing.
Let me fire it myself. Yeah, I'm gonna me
Pass fire.
Okay.
Okay. Do you understand the gist of it, right?
Yeah, I understand it,
but yeah, I think the link, uh,
linking the link in the click here to find out more details.
Hello? It, it's not working.
There's no link advantage to it. Attaching to it.
Okay, hold on. Hey coffee, Alyssa.
Um, you think I can get your help with something?
I know you're busy, but this is kind of important.
Okay, So, um,
what's the subject line?
Subject line meeting for Owen? Event?
Yeah, because I haven't got it yet. Spam.
Yeah. Um, at first it goes to my spam.
Mm-hmm.
Promotions, social.
Yeah, I don't have nothing.
All mail spam.
What'd you say the subject was
Meeting four O and event.
Huh? So Yeah, it's coming from Owen Cook himself
Be nicely. 32
detail. Yeah.
No, I didn't send, oh no, it did send,
but it's not showing.
Oh yeah. Workflow is, duh. I'm looking for a broadcast.
It's a workflow.
Yep. Um, coffee.
I know you didn't do this, but Ahmad's not here anymore.
This is pulling in custom fields
that are assigned when the tag fires off.
Right?
Right. If I show you
over here, this is the workflow.
And so if I open this up, is, is this correct, Keith?
Um, there's no, uh, time and date. Towards date and time.
Yeah. There's nothing in the subject.
Only meeting for Owen Event.
Okay, but hold on a minute.
Did we actually update that in the tag?
I don't think we did. Did we?
Um, tag actions custom fields.
So we have venue Look, we don't have it. Hold on.
Coffee may, maybe I don't, hold on. So we need to have date.
And what was the date again?
Uh, 20. Hold on, let just double check.
February 28th, 2021. Yeah.
Right? Yep.
Oops. Okay. Oh my gosh, it won't let me do it.
No, I don't, I don't wanna do that. I, okay, you know what?
I don't like that. So
contact fields date, we're gonna change this
to a text
and, okay, let's see if that's better.
So we go back to the tags.
Do you understand what's happening right now, Keith, or no?
Yeah, I understand. Okay, so date
Feb 28th through March
One, One, save.
Okay, and then we have to do time.
And what time is it gonna be again?
3:00 PM to pm.
So let's do this again since I don't
know if that's gonna work, right?
Let's just make the time a text field too.
In the future, you won't wanna do this
because we wanna be able to send off the date
and time at a specific time in the workflows,
but right now it's okay.
Just remember later we need
to change it when we get to that point.
So I'm just gonna make the field type text, okay?
Say we go back to tag. Okay?
So tag actions, custom fields,
date, time.
Say it again, Hannah.
Um, it's at 8:00 PM The 12:00 AM
Okay.
All right, so now Keith, I'm gonna fire off that tag again.
And did you see it in the, oh, we gotta see if we see it.
Okay.
Okay. And let's see it if we see it now
Yet.
Nothing. Yeah, nothing. Okay. I think, yeah, I got it.
Yeah, the date is in there now.
Okay, so the dates in the subject line, right?
Yeah. And the dates in the
Events, dates in the body,
And you understand why it wasn't the first
time, right? Yeah.
Okay, So now,
'cause Keith, I want you to take all this over
'cause I'm too scatterbrained to do it, right?
Mm-hmm. So coffee, I think the only thing
that we need from you is if you can,
this link right here should go
to whatever is in this short code,
right? Uh,
It's not working right now.
No. So this is the, well,
let me make sure that we updated it.
Did we update it Keith?
Like if you don't update the tag, then it can't
because I know for a fact, yeah, it's right here.
Coffee. So it should go here
and it's not doing that right Keith?
Yeah.
Okay. I need to check.
Yeah, if you can just check
that coffee, that would be good.
So Keith, what I would do is I would, do you know
that you can export out these contacts again?
Are you getting pretty good at that?
Exporting con, uh, contacts?
These are all the people tagged? Mm-hmm.
Yeah, But I mean, sure you have 'em in another list.
So what you can do tomorrow is once you get
that workflow built out,
coffee will fix that one thing for you.
Okay? Reimport in the tags.
Make sure you got all your emails there.
Make sure the the timers are set
so they'll get 'em before this weekend.
Okay? And That's it. You're, you're done.
They'll get the emails in a timely manner,
it'll automatically pull in the details
and then you set for every single event, all you ever need
to do is once you get the details, update the event,
update the workflow, and then boom, import the tags
and then we'll get, um, coffee.
I can't remember, didn't we get texts set up over here?
Weren't you the one that did that?
That was on development?
I'm not sure if we can do that for production.
We did it for Twilio. Uh, yes.
Is it in the, in the dev? Is that what you're saying?
Uh, I guess so.
Hold on, let me see something that equals true.
Yeah, but we had it working. We just never tested it.
Let's see, QR codes,
S-M-S-S-M-S numbers Add SMS number,
select account, self-mastery, select a number,
uh, add.
So now Twilio's connected.
So when we're in the workflow
broadcast domains, workflows,
and we come over here, we
set it up to where we could go like this, right?
Mm-hmm. And then we choose a
number, save.
And then you put your text message here.
Didn't we build that coffee?
Uh, yes.
Um, it probably will not pull
the short codes though, right?
Right. But it could,
Yeah, I can check if we can, uh, pull that.
I'm just gonna do this test for real quick for myself.
One test. Okay?
So, um,
do you have the phone number for most of the people anyways?
Keith?
Uh, I don't have it. I can just check it manually in the
contacts and also in the cart if it's available.
What I'm saying is we don't have a phone number over here.
These people, we don't have phone
numbers in their contact record.
Yeah, because if you did
Not all of them. Yeah,
But Hold on.
Yeah, but I can get it in the card,
but I think not all of them are in here.
Only 14 contacts are in here.
And I will be sending supposedly 20.
Let me see if I get a text.
Do you think I'll get a text? Coffee?
Yeah. Really?
Um,
No, I didn't get nothing, but that's okay.
We can look into it. Um,
but that's what you want to have happen, Keith.
That's the ultimate.
Did you deal with workflows in, uh, go high level at all?
Mm-hmm. This is pretty easy. Yes.
Yeah, This is a lot easier, right? Would you agree?
Yeah, it's, it is easier.
It just so happened that you need to, um,
make sure the custom field is working well.
So Yeah, it might link,
it will link when you're using the tags in the SMS
or you know.
Yeah. But what go high level couldn't do is we can open up
open Claw and I can say, Hey, take Joe blow@gmail.com
and fire off 11 dash San Diego
and see what just happened.
Mm-hmm. They're now getting texts emails,
so remind me and we'll see if coffee
can look at that next week.
If we get freed up with what we're doing
or not, we can see if we can get the text to work, right?
Coffee?
Yes. It might be something simple
because I remember you had it working.
I guess you need to, uh, you need
to put the full number maybe with the plus one.
Is that what it is? Uh, it can be.
So,
oops.
Okay, so you're saying
plus 1 3 0 7 2 5 9 1 0 6, like that?
Yes.
Would that number show if there was a problem
in his Twilio account?
Uh, coffee. Would that number still show?
Uh, yeah, it can be
because we are just pulling the number from the Twilio.
Okay.
I didn't get it, but it's okay.
You, he's got enough to work on.
So do you understand what we need to do now, Keith?
You gotta keep building that out. Make them unique.
Mm-hmm. I'm gonna rely on you to do that.
I'm not gonna do that myself,
but coffee, if you can just look into
that little link issue for him.
Okay? You can always put a, a timer up here too.
There's reasons why you would do that, right?
But right now you probably don't have to do that,
right? So you get the flow.
Yeah, I get the flow. Uh, can I have a request chat
before we end this call?
Yeah. Um, do you have the recording for yourself, right?
Just to make sure I got all the details correct.
And I'm not gonna,
It goes into, it goes into Zoom,
hammock, hanock can get it for you.
Okay. All right. Thanks.
Um, the other thing, uh, okay, coffee.
That's all I needed from you bud
Uhhuh. Okay,
Thanks.
Bye-bye. Bye.
Um,
uh, cell pages.
Okay. So this is the one you did
for RSD, right?
Yeah.
Okay. Uh, let me show you
think.
You see this over here. We've, we're starting
to connect stuff together.
See that? Mm-hmm. Sprout.
You can see how it logged me in.
Um, so let's go here.
Pricing option. No, I gotta go here. Pricing options.
Okay, so we go look at RSD
or self mastery.
Yeah. So if we go look at the actives in self-mastery,
like, is all this starting to make sense to you?
So he's, we've got 3000 active clickers in self mastery
and that's what I'm trying to do in his AI company now.
9,000 openers, 3000 clickers, right? That's pretty good.
We could do a good business with that
and we can keep trying to reengage over here.
So we need to be sending out this, um,
this one here pretty soon.
But I'll tell you something else we can do with it.
So this is gonna sound a little confusing,
but just try to understand,
'cause I need you to set this up.
So if I come over here to my
pods, I have two pods, I go to my pricing options.
Um, let me think.
I go to my pricing options, which is the one
that has the most pricing options.
Okay? So we start with this one.
I, and if I click
cone download, hold on.
Let me just think here for a minute. I come over here.
Payment setup. Is it over here? Maybe?
No, it should be over here. Okay.
This is what's included.
Okay? It's in here.
I go to my pricing options option payment
setup there.
That's what I'm looking for.
I don't know why that didn't appear.
Okay, so Transformation Mastery. Okay, so we come over here.
Mm-hmm. Okay.
So this is everything they're getting access to inside
of this one pricing option. Yeah.
Yeah, But I can say
they could get all,
and so what I have to do is, the first thing we have to do
is we have to sort, you know, what is RSD?
And you know what self-mastery is, right?
Yeah. I think I know the difference. Okay.
But, um, if you're gonna go to go
and look into the SMC page, it's mixed up.
Mm. Okay.
This here is SMC, right?
Yeah. Some products crossover,
Yes, But not many.
Okay? So like, this stuff is,
this stuff always bothers me, right?
So if the duh is screwing it up, just go,
Oh, okay, Just go like that.
You see, like, I'm really,
really big on keeping things in line.
Um, like even this one transformation mastery,
Oh, it's the same.
Well, we'll call it transcend
mastery, then it doesn't matter.
Just make sure our pages look good, right? Mm-hmm. Okay.
So
high vibe, diamond,
High vibe. Yeah. I cleaned up
for you. So what do you wanna do?
Yeah, I can do that. I can clean it for you.
Yeah. Okay. So just make sure things are always lined up,
saying spacing.
Yeah. Okay. Um, all right, so you get all that?
Mm-hmm. Okay. Like these look horrible though.
Yeah. Um,
yeah.
You know what, if I was you,
I would remove anything that's a duplicate,
Right?
Unless you can ask Chad GPT to create one
that says business mentoring.
Mm-hmm. Actually, I just asked Anna for that.
To change the business.
Yeah, the social skill to business. Yeah.
Yeah. But like this, yeah, it just doesn't make sense.
You only need one. It doesn't mean they don't get everything
else, it just means you don't have
to duplicate it like that.
Okay? So you can clean that up, right?
Yeah, I can clean that. Okay, so clean that up.
You already took the extra stuff off, right? Is it 4 97?
Okay, so let's mail this thing out.
So we're gonna come over here and we're gonna link
to the product, okay?
So it's already linked, okay? Yep.
So next, what we can do inside
of member, it's kind of special.
You can fire off a tag that says gold,
but also look, we can come over here to, um,
the product digital,
and then the gold one.
Okay? See membership integration. Mm-hmm.
You can put them member will put them directly
into the right product.
Okay? But you just have to know which one it is.
I there one that says gold.
Yep. Gold.
POD Chunk one free.
PODI guess it's chunk one. I don't know. Oh, right here.
Okay, that's the main one. So you turn on active.
And so what happens is when somebody buy this, uh, uh,
course Sprout will send out the email and give 'em access.
Okay? So what we need to do though is always, always,
always look at this product,
edit the order form, okay?
I like to use this one even though it doesn't matter
because there's a two step order form on the
page, right? Mm-hmm.
Mm-hmm. Yeah. Okay. You get that part.
But this over here, you still need to set.
And so there's a confirmation page
that is Purchase general, see?
So you need to make sure that you use this page
for everything we have
Purchase General, okay?
Okay. So now somebody's gonna click that page,
fill out the form, uh,
once they fill out the form, they're gonna see this page.
And then it's gonna go, let's make sure
that this is the right password.
I think it is. Let's see,
we gotta go look at the pricing option, right?
So we gotta go find gold, RSD, gold.
So now we come over here, we click on the email.
Is it RSD or the goal? PD? It's not, it's, it's, uh,
2 9 7 2 9 6. Sorry,
2, 9 6.
Yeah, there. No, that's free. Go
Up, go up. Yep.
This is Self-mastery. Yeah,
That's the one that you choose in the dropdown earlier.
Okay? Now what we have to do is
phone, phone, phone, phone, phone.
Let's see, gold Pod.
Okay? See this here? You just have to make sure
that matches what's in the email, right?
Mm-hmm. Okay. Is this making sense?
Yeah. Okay.
So your email set up, your product goes
to an order form, right?
And any questions so far, or no?
Uh, nothing. Uh, it's always default.
The password is as, as mc,
there's no option for me to change it. It
I just showed you. I just showed
you where you could change it.
I know. Um, what I mean in that page.
I'll just copy that always. No,
You can, you can change this.
You can change this. This is a confirmation page over here.
Yeah. This, this whole page can change.
Do you understand? Look, I can change it.
The only one you can't change is that event page.
It's dynamic. This is not dynamic, right?
So we wanna make sure that this is linked to here.
Oh, shoot, what did I do?
I, okay, Self
mass rico.com/numbers, save changes.
Okay. Does that make sense? Yeah.
All Any questions?
Uh, none so far.
And then they're gonna take this survey.
So I saw where you tagged those guys
that they had a hot lead today.
Well, that's because people are clicking here
and they're coming over here.
Mm-hmm. See how this works?
Yeah. All right, so now we go back to there.
So you fix this page,
and now what we need to do is, right now I want you
to hand write an email, a broadcast that will go
to this page.
Uh, so this is gonna be, which one's the right one?
I don't know. I, I don't know what you got going on here.
You gotta clean this up. So, um,
There's an RSD on the left, and the right one is SMC.
Okay? So this one's RSD. Yeah.
And also it changed the logo as well there.
Okay.
Main pages, sales pages.
Okay, so now look, refresh.
What the heck? Okay, there we go. All right.
So remember though, when we promote,
we don't promote the sales page,
we're gonna promote the sales funnel.
Mm-hmm. Right? So if we click in here, what did we build?
I don't even remember this, this,
and yeah, purchase general.
See, so what you wanna watch out
for self mastery.com/gold self
mastery.com/all that.
Okay? So if I try to do that, well, let me do it. Okay?
And then this one over here, uh,
it's just a confirmation page.
The the thing is, and I want you
to start looking out for this stuff.
We were, we were, I was moving so fast that
things were not named properly.
So lemme see. Bootcamp. Bootcamp.
I actually don't know why it's saying that.
Let me see again. Gold membership.
Okay, let's, let's click this out.
Add step confirmation page, purchase general. There you go.
And so now we can do just purchase confirmation like this.
Okay? So now you have clean, clean, clean, any questions?
Mm-hmm. And then this domain is set
over here under settings.
Here's the Stripe account. Okay?
So is this the right page, I hope?
Yeah. SMC Yeah, that's the right one.
Okay, so this is the actual funnel.
This is the, this is the link
that you would put inside of an email.
Does that make sense?
Okay, I got it. So
I'm gonna, and what I wanna do is I wanna turn around
and have his, I wanna put all three
of his products on this page for another 4 97
and see if we can get it.
Okay? But I'll, I'll do that later.
So now I wanna show you something else.
So we're gonna come over here and everything
that is part of the gold package.
So we come back over here.
If we look at all these products, okay, you're gonna have
to see inside that gold one.
Like we're not giving this away, right?
This is not part of free.
Mm-hmm. So self-mastery,
self-mastery, everything
that is self-mastery.
You put this link here, everything that's RSD,
you put the RSD link there.
Okay? Does that make sense? Yeah, makes sense.
Now, here's the reason why. When we go back into,
let's start with the one that's got the most,
which is this guy, when we come over here
and we click on launch courses, we can say all.
And so what that means is when people log in here,
they're gonna see a lock
that says you got 35 courses locked.
Oh, okay. So let me see if I can do this for you.
Okay, let's look at,
um, SMC free.
No, that's not the main one, right?
There's a free pod, right? Free that has a lot. RSD free.
Hold on, let me just do self-mastery.
Gold, gold one.
Okay. Free pod.
Uh, I don't know
what the main one is for
free, okay.
SMC free pod. It says 25 though. That can't be right.
All right, so let's go down to one of these ones down here.
Free pod. Free pod two.
Okay. Free pod two.
Free pod one, okay, I'm gonna do this one here.
So free pod two, chunk one, okay, I'm gonna come over here.
Lock courses. I'm gonna say all
Now the reason why it's only
showing these is 'cause guess what?
Isn't that where I put the URL? No. Yes it is.
I just showed you, I went into each course
and I gave it the URL gave it the URL gave it.
The URL gave it the UL. Oh, okay. Uh, yeah. Now watch.
I'm just gonna say all. So this was what?
Free pod two, right? It was this one. Free pod two.
Okay, so watch, I'm gonna go members, add members,
ch James,
CI, c3, three at G,
or I'm gonna say uh, free
pod@gmail.com
and test user free pod@gmail.com.
Okay? So we're only gonna give 'em access to, uh, that one
Gold Free Pod two.
It's this one. Yeah, I'll say demo.
Demo. Okay, so we have test user. Do you see what I did?
Free pod@gmail.com. All right, so let's try this.
Let's see what happens. So we're gonna come over here
and I'm gonna log out,
or at least I'm gonna try to,
it's gonna keep me logged in until I load that picture.
Um, self mastery
co.com/members.
And what was the name of the,
what was the name of the Free?
Yeah, it was Free pod@gmail.com. And then password demo.
Okay, so I have to do this.
Okay. Profile pictures.
Okay, so I do that.
All right, so now here's the free pod, right? Mm-hmm.
Um, let me see. Why isn't it showing?
It should show over here. Hold on a second.
What did I do wrong? Why isn't it showing over there?
The, it should show those four over here.
Pricing options. Okay, let me make sure I did the right one.
Free Pod
1 1 2.
Which man, these are so confusing.
Let me do Self mastery free
Pod two.
It was this one, right? Free pod two dash chunk one.
And if I click here, Oh, it's a different one.
I don't know. I get this stuff so confused, dude.
All right, so let's come back over here.
I'm telling you, I am not good at this stuff.
I waste so much time 'cause I get so confused. There you go.
Locked courses. So now they're in the free one
and they can see it, right?
Mm-hmm. But now they're gonna see 35 locked courses.
Do you think they're gonna click that?
And when they do, they come over here
and right now it's going to the end
of the year, but it shouldn't be.
So we'll have to see why all those
are going to the end of the year.
Because if we look at Transformation Mastery,
now let's go back over to the course
and let's look at Transformation Mastery.
Transformation Mastery,
self Mastery.
Okay, is there a couple? Transformation Mastery.
Transformation Mastery,
okay.
Yeah, there's a bunch of these things.
Okay, let's try again.
Why it's doing that? I have no idea.
Lot courses. Why is it going there?
This one is, this one is what?
Transformation Mastery.
Standard Transformation. Mastery Standard.
Hold on a second, I'm missing something.
Transformation Mastery. Is it standard? Standard?
Yeah. Why is it going?
Hold on a second. Course links inter,
oh, I think the link is different.
I need to go there. Yeah, I just, I just totally see,
I'm telling you, dude, I can build software.
I can't run it. Okay,
so we do this, we do this.
See, you knew what the problem was.
You said you should have said them earlier.
I'm telling you, dude, I'm an idiot with this stuff.
Nobody believes me. They're like, oh, you're so smart.
I'm like, no, no, no.
All right, so we come in here, we set all these.
So that way when you go inside of there,
and we get to do this with RSD,
and we get to do this with SMC, now we refresh.
And what's it say for courses? We click it and boom.
Now they're gonna go and they buy this.
And when they do, what happens?
Keith, it unlocks it.
If this is the right one,
I don't think this is the right one, because that
Is the old one. It's
not the one that I made.
So what does that tell me?
That tells me that our funnel is wrong.
So we gotta go back in the Funnel Uhhuh sales page.
It's fine. The funnel's wrong.
So Sales funnel, we come in here
and we're gonna get rid of this one.
So unfortunately we can't change it.
We gotta start all over.
And I gotta tell you, it's really, really hard
to do this, right?
You gotta add a step sales page.
Which one is it? This one right?
One? Yeah, that one. SMC.
And this one upsell. This one.
Confirmation page. This one? Yeah.
So now we click here and we're gonna do gold.
And here I'm do this,
and here I'm gonna do this.
Make sense? Are you getting it?
Yeah, I'm getting it. It's a pretty
easy software, isn't it?
Mm-hmm. Over here. All that's still the same. Okay, perfect.
Now, holy crap,
I go back into here, I guess.
And let's try this.
Reload. Four courses,
unlock Self-mastery Gold.
There you go. So once you fix that page, it'll be good.
The Buy Now buttons always need to jump to the order form.
Did you figure that out? The,
the buy buttons can jump to the order form, right?
All these ones, these ones appear. Um,
Yeah, I think I should remove that special bonus
because that's the one with the face of NDA to other ladies.
I hope you're super smart
because you're gonna be on your own
with this stuff here pretty quick.
So look, gold offer, where does the gold offer start?
The gold offer starts right here. Mm-hmm.
And the name of this section is red.
Well, we should call it Gold Offer.
So edit this Guy Gold Offer.
Okay? Mm-hmm.
So now when we're up here, we click here,
this link, scroll to section Gold offer.
Boom. Save this guy.
We'll get rid of this guy.
Uh, I don't know if that's the right one. Maybe. Okay, save.
There you go. Now that,
that can also jump to here.
See? Mm-hmm.
And all these buttons can jump to the order form. Got it?
Yeah. Any questions?
Now remember, you also gotta take this URL
and you gotta look at it on the phone.
I showed you that, right? Yeah,
You showed me that.
Okay, so we take the funnel link,
which is here, copy or see Keith.
This is, this is all stuff AI
can do. Do you understand that?
Yeah. This stuff still requires a human, right?
Once it's repetitive over and over and over, it can.
But right now, no. So we gotta take all that.
So there's two things. There's three things I need you
to do in the two hours you got left.
Number one, finish your workflow.
Number two, write the email for your gold offer.
Send that out. You can send it to your openers.
You can send it to your clickers. You gotta start learning
that and you're not gonna reengage with it.
'cause it's gonna be a sell, right?
It's gonna be a promo, yeah.
Mm-hmm. And you wanna find a way
to pull a nice image into the email.
And then number three, go into your course route.
Start linking your gold offer
and your for both so that we can go into the pricing options
and just click a button that says All, all, all.
And that way, whenever people log in, they see
that extra option
and that thing's gonna start making money on its
own because mm-hmm.
People are in here and
they're going through all the old courses.
Tell me they're not gonna click on these.
Go ahead, I dare you.
Of course they're gonna click this, right? They'll,
Yeah, they'll, And when they do, that offer
that you're creating is so good
that we're gonna start making sales.
And Nick said, our only goal is to make one sale a day.
So if you're mailing and we have this happening,
and we're, if we're re-engaging, guess what?
We're gonna start making sales, right? Mm-hmm.
Yeah. All right. Any questions?
I'll tell you what I'll go through
and I'll link all the courses for you to save you time.
Uh, if you could just go turn on the ones
that have the most, I mean, we need to go
through all the privacy, all the, all the options,
and flip that all button, right?
And all it's gonna show is the ones
that actually have URLs assigned.
So I'll go sign all the URLs to the products real quick
so it's not confusing for you.
And then when you get the time,
you can go turn on all the options
and that way this will show like 35 or whatever.
It's okay.
Okay. Is that good?
Yeah, it's a lot. But I think I got it.
I think you got it. Just do your workflow,
write your broadcast.
I'll do this part and then we can do this. Okay? Yeah.
Can I, uh, can I have the recording iPlay?
Yes, please. Okay.
Yeah, don't beat yourself up over it.
Just take what you can. The main thing
was the workflow, right?
Yeah. Workflow. I mean, look, dude,
you can't do any worse than me.
I screw everything up. So I think you'll be fine.
Yeah. All right. Thanks for that.
Yeah. And guys, look, man, look, Hannah, you're dealing
with a broken AI right now, right?
Mm-hmm. Right?
This company guys had like 50 employees a year ago.
We're down to U2, we're down to U three, and that's it.
So you guys are fine. Just do the best you can.
Let's make sure that we get at least one sale a day.
And that's fine. That's, that, that's a,
that's a pretty easy thing, right?
Let's shoot as for as many sales as we can get,
but as long as we get one a day,
if we get one $500 sale a day, he's happy right now.
Mm-hmm. Okay. Yeah.
We're also fighting for our life with the refund in here.
Yeah, I got that too.
So that's why you wanna make a lot of sales, right?
But Nick's helping you with that, isn't he?
Um, yeah.
I'm not giving any refunds after,
but he said though, I'm, there are customers
who are getting really mad,
but I just have to listen to Nick with request
that he, as much as possible, if we cannot give it to them,
you know, um, I have one customer in here, I'm waiting
for Nick to respond, but he's not replying things yesterday.
Is he out?
He's dealing with an issue in LA right now.
He should be back Thursday.
Oh, okay. Um, yeah,
because, um, I need the access to the contracts
that the customer signed.
Okay. There, there is someone in here who's really,
he has $10,000 transaction.
Well, the thing is, guys, the money
that this company can be making is very, very minimal,
but we gotta get these things in place.
Mm-hmm. And unfortunately for Nick, right about the time
that Claudia was pulling her stuff
and everything, Hannah, I started focusing really
heavy on the other company.
And now you can see that I've
created a mess in the other company.
And so I can't really focus that much time on like
what we're doing right now.
So I'm just trying to give you guys little bits
and pieces that will keep this company, you know, going and,
and then I gotta get through the mess
that I created in our own company first, right?
'cause I got a frenzy. Like everybody's going nuts.
And we got a big webinar tomorrow.
We got a launch right around the corner.
I think we're gonna do really, really well.
And then I can come back over here and focus on this.
But if we can just put these things in place
where the free tours are getting delivered on the people
going through the membership are upselling,
and then we're getting emails out consistently on those
offers right now, Keith, I think we'll be good guys.
I think he'll be happy.
Yeah. All right, so work on those things.
I'm gonna go work on this webinar for tomorrow, but I'll go
and link all these things real quick, Keith, so
that when you turn 'em on, you
understand the goal now, right?
And you understand that you could go into whatever account,
like I have that test member now you could go into test
member, remove this option and give it a different option,
and then you could see what he's seen.
Do you understand? Mm-hmm.
Yeah. But, but you,
what you wanna see is the free one consists of eight courses
and this one should have like 35 locked courses
and then they get 'em all when they buy that one product.
Mm-hmm. How about a, in RSD, there's only a few.
Like same thing. Same thing.
There's a few unlocked
and then there's a lot of locked ones.
Right. Okay.
All right. But I'll focus in the workflow first.
I'll make sure I'm gonna do that.
Lemme know if you have questions, okay?
Okay. Yeah. All right. Bye-bye.
All right, thanks. You're welcome.